Come come gather round class!
I've built in self preparing armor,
nano liquid circuitry,
full spectrum scanning and bunch of other big words
What else can it do? well lucky for you
I wrote you an instruction manual
Yay
I'll look at this later
GUYS THE SUITS FREAKING OUT!
Get It Off!
I Can't Get It Off!!
What the hell does he need a raft for Cisco??
He runs on water
It seemed like a smart idea at the time !
Barry why do you think iris wanted you to to see me today?
Well, we recently started working together. You canceled training the other day without asking me
training for
swimming
Marathon
Tria
thlon
We're not on the same page people could die like if they crashed into a brick wall going 100 miles per hour metaphorically
The weight of the whole city falls on my shoulders, I'm the flash
You are not the flash Barry
We Are
I trust you Iris
Run Barry
Run
Hey look it's the flash
If I were you I would start running
Hey everybody we got new flash, let's break this down Danny Trejo is finally coming and he's gonna kick the shit out of Cisco
It's gonna be so funny
There's a new round of that Justice League ticket giveaway - all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
Leave a comment on this video it I'll announce a new winner at the end of this
so this is really like two clips that they released they're doing a little bit better job of promoting the show this year so at
The beginning you have all that stuff focusing on the tech that Cisco built into the new suit
They're gonna use it for a little bit of comedy
But they also want to hype up how cool it is it actually has a legit heads-up display
So the fact that Cisco's manual is that thick implies that there's a bunch of other stuff that he built into it?
They might use that in future episodes, but a lot of you probably recognize this big
You know super fat flash from the comic book
You know this very famous comic book cover where the Flash's mass is increased so he can barely run
It's just this funny comic book cover that doesn't totally make sense out of context
You're like why is the flash so fat now like what happened to him did he eat too much is actually from the flash?
Volume one number
115 and the name of the story is the day the flash weighed a thousand pounds
But because there's two stories in that comic book the other one is an
Elongated man story, so the elongated man is going to be one of the characters that comes on the show this year
I don't think we're gonna see him in episode 2
But you can see how a lot of the Easter eggs sort of tease at what's coming up on the flash
But the thing about the comic book story is that it was actually Gorilla Grodd
taking control of another person's mind called William Dawson who constructed a device to increase the Flash's mass so that he would weigh a
Thousand pounds and slow him down
So it was more of a story about Gorilla Grodd trying to hurt the flash by controlling someone else which we know the thinker is
Doing as well
But we might also get more teasers for the blacksmith character Amunet black who's also
Controlling other people in Central City mostly the Rogues the main villain of the episode is somebody else who can control technology
He's like a techno path so that goes back to the thinker because those are some of his comic book abilities during the Jeff John's
run but I think I've said it in videos before
Where a lot of the villains and the problems that Barry faces are sort of teeing up
Ideas that will be important later on when he fights the thinker directly. There's a lot of cool moments with him just running around
Dismantling cars trying to save people
It looks like he goes a little bit nuts just because he's so happy to be out of the Speed Force you see him
Partying at a bar which seems kind of out of place, so maybe there's some big victory that he's celebrating like the Flash's back
Everybody's really happy so maybe he's just a little drunk on the attention, but let's talk about Danny Trejo here
So I don't know how big he's going to be in the back half of the season
but the thing that brings him on the show this time is because he and gipsy have been going out in the background for the
Past six months or so while the show's been off the air
So now it's gotten to the point where she's like okay
You need to meet my dad so Danny Trejo shows up in the comics
He has the same abilities as Cisco and gipsy, so we'll see what his powers are like on the TV show
But I think that everybody kind of understands what's going on here
It's just like the really angry dad who's protective of his daughter. Who's gonna go after Cisco
Who doesn't totally take things seriously until he sees how scary Gipsy's father is if you were dating Danny Trejo's daughter
And he looked at you like he's looking at Cisco right here. You would probably shit your pants, too
We also see earth to Harrison Wells who's coming back and looks like he's explaining something to Wally. This is probably him telling him
What's going on with Jesse quick?
And I think there might be some sort of break up
Situation to explain why she's not gonna be on the show the first half of the season
Or if she is is going to be
very briefly as far as I know the actress who plays Jesse quick has not been seen on set so I don't know when she's
Going to come back, but she will come back. Eventually the thing about Harrison wells this season
They said is that because Jesse's pretty much got everything all locked down
He needs to find something to do with himself because they've solved all their problems on earth, too
I think that's why he comes back to STAR Labs
But they did say that his story will get tied up in the thinker
So we'll just have to see you know what it is
That's going on with him specifically this mummy looks a little bit out of place
So we'll have to see if there's some weird explanation for this like if it's a legit mummy
Or if it has something to do with the villain of the episode and it's like an animatronic
Dummy and in the villain who's controlling the technology inside of it
But that's part of the reason why I love the flash is because they do a lot of hard science science fiction stuff
But you could also do a zombies story, too
And it would still feel like comic book flash so as far as the therapy stuff goes
I don't know how much they're using this for comedy and whether or not it'll turn into more of a
Sopranos therapy thing but because of the lighter tone of the season, I'm
Expecting them to just use it to deal with irises new position in how Barry
Integrates her into the team because while he was away they sort of had their new team flash and now that he's back and crazy
Overpowered he's just trying to do everything by himself
Which will of course end in disaster that kind of feels like something the thinker would really enjoy the flash being all by himself
Usually the character strengths on all these TV shows are their teams so things go off the rails when they go rogue and try to
Do things by themselves, but everybody let me know what you think about the first couple of episodes
There are a couple of big things from episode 1 that
I might do bonus videos for this weekend like the thinker's symbols on his face
Look a lot like the symbols that Barry is drawing after he came out of the Speed Force, so there's probably a connection there
They're also the same symbols on that thug that's working for the blacksmith - so mystery code. Everything is connected
There's a conspiracy in the background so we could talk about that this weekend, but because there's so much superhero stuff
I do have a legends of tomorrow episode 1 video coming, but I have a Thor warbound clip that
I'll probably post next just because there's been so much DC content for the last day or so there won't be quite as much flash
Next week I did a couple extra videos
Because it's the premiere so as long as you have alerts enabled you should get all the videos YouTube broke a little bit last night
But I think it's fine now
Congratulations to the latest giveaway winner George Keith
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
I'll name a new winner when I post that legends of tomorrow video later tonight
While you wait for everything you can click here for my flash episode 1 Easter egg video
And you can click here to watch that final flash versus thinker scene again. Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight